[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo
meta la dueña de Facebook estaría
preparando el lanzamiento de una
aplicación que sería la competencia
directa de Twitter será esta una de las
tantas plataformas que han surgido como
alternativa a la red social o por el
contrario la vasta infraestructura de la
compañía le ayudará a tomarle ventaja a
Twitter luego de los polémicos cambios
implementados por su nuevo dueño elon
musk aquí lo analizamos empezamos
[Música]
así luce la que sería la interfaz de la
nueva aplicación de meta la dueña de
Facebook y que sería la competencia
directa de Twitter la imagen fue
mostrada a los empleados de la compañía
durante una reunión de toda la empresa y
fue obtenida por el portal de verse de
acuerdo con este sitio web de noticias
tecnológicas el nombre interno de la
aplicación es proyecto 92 Pero según
documentos a los que pudo acceder su
nombre público podría ser que significa
hilos en palabras del director de
producto de metacriscogs esta nueva
plataforma es su respuesta a Twitter y
su objetivo será la seguridad la
facilidad de uso y la confiabilidad
Además ya están en conversaciones con
personalidades como opra o el dalai Lama
para que sean los primeros usuarios
hemos escuchado de creadores y figuras
públicas que están interesados en tener
una plataforma que se administre de
manera sensata en la que puedan creer y
confiar Este es otro de los intentos por
arrebatarle terreno a Twitter y por el
cual han surgido diversas aplicaciones
sobre todo después de que el
multimillonario elon musk comprara la
compañía e implementar a una serie de
cambios Como por ejemplo cobrar por ser
usuario verificado y eliminar las reglas
de moderación de contenido veamos Cuáles
son algunas alternativas que han surgido
al pájaro azul una de ellas es más de
origen alemán y que como su sitio web lo
indica nació en 2016 ante la
insatisfacción de su fundador con el
estado y la dirección de Twitter de
acuerdo con sus estadísticas tiene 1,2
millones de usuarios activos mensuales y
está disponible en 20 idiomas otra es q
con sede en India el segundo sitio de
microblogging más grande del mundo y
aunque solo tiene tres años en el
mercado tiene 4,1
de usuarios activos mensuales según
cuenta a la prensa local y está
disponible en 15 idiomas y finalmente
tenemos 3 social del expresidente Donald
Trump que precisamente nació a raíz de
que el ex mandatario fue expulsado de
Twitter y otras plataformas luego del
ataque al Capitolio en 2021 según medios
estadounidenses de derecha true social
cuenta con unos 2,8 millones de usuarios
activos mensuales y de acuerdo con la
información brindada por la página de
aplicaciones de Apple solo está
disponible en inglés y en portugués las
tres funcionan casi igual a Twitter se
puede publicar un mensaje corto
repostera la publicación de una persona
comentarla o darle me gusta seguir a
otros usuarios y hasta etiquetarlos pero
a pesar de sus similitudes ninguna de
estas redes sociales Ha logrado ser una
competencia directa de Twitter es esta
acaso una compañía indestronable que ha
contribuido a que Twitter se mantenga
qué tiene Twitter que no tienen estas
otras se lo preguntamos a Iván Jiménez
experto en tecnología
lo que Twitter hace es que tiene una
comunidad amplísima a nivel mundial
tiene con micro comunidades cada una con
con una afiliación o o un una razón de
ser particular y luego A eso le sumamos
el hecho de que era obviamente
un generador de de información de de
Primicia porque a nivel mundial tenía
micro comunidades que se dedicaban a un
esfuerzo particular entonces y en
tiempos récord o sea donde también lo lo
tenías en un muy corto tiempo como lo
hacen aún la el el reto para los
competidores es poder tener esa esa
amplitud de participación a nivel
mundial pero pero recordemos que aunque
es mundial es pequeño en cuanto a mí al
usuario porque es mi comunidad la que se
dedica a al tema que es de relevancia o
importancia para mí en el día de hoy
Iván Jiménez también nos habló sobre el
impacto que se espera que tenga la nueva
plataforma creada por meta cuyas
aplicaciones también han estado bajo
escrutinio por cuestiones de privacidad
si si hay uno que podría llegar o podría
inclusive desplazar a Twitter es meta
claro meta tiene la comunidad tiene la
la plataforma tiene el la usanza de
Instagram entonces van a utilizar
todo todo lo que corresponde a Facebook
Instagram para hasta así poder diríamos
captar ese usuario que que aunque tal
vez tenía esas otras cuentas pues
accedía Twitter para esas cápsulas y
reseñas pequeñas y pero igual no es que
Twitter se va a quedar con los brazos
cruzados también Ellos están pensando
tener otras aplicaciones sobre su base
la aplicación de de videollamadas y de
llamadas de teléfono para competir con
WhatsApp pero volviendo a meta meta
tiene esa amplia base de usuarios que
ahora podría captar ese segmento de uso
que es el de enviar
cápsulas pequeñas y poder así abrazar
más el cliente que tiene de esta manera
despedimos este capítulo de revista
digital recuerde que si quieres repetir
este u otro episodio de nuestro programa
lo puede hacer A través de nuestra
página web triple W punto franz24.com
[Música]